Honestly, the only reason
I'm doing this is
because nobody ever tags me in
these survey things and I feel left out.
So, there's the truth.
I didn't do this last year, so today
I'm going to answer all of the questions
from both of the surveys from last year
and this year in no particular order. Let's go.
My full name is
Charles Joseph McDonnell,
McDonnell meaning "son of Donnell,"
which I've never really understood,
although we do have a
family crest, so that's quite cool.
Joseph was my paternal
granddad's name,
and Charles came because
my parents liked it,
although I didn't,
clearly, hence Charlie.
My username came about because
I originally wanted charlieiscool,
but that was taken, so I added some
more words, and that's the whole story.
So this coat is my most
expensive item of clothing.
£50 at Topman.
I am not an adventurous
clothes buyer, sorry.
I do, however, sometimes spend embarrassingly
large amounts of money on other things.
For example, my chair
cost me over £700,
which is more money than some
people spend on their first car,
and my chair doesn't
have an engine.
Now although there's no correct
time to have your first kiss,
as one of the later bloomers
in the area of "lady intimacy,"
I was pretty obsessed with the fact
that I just had to have my kiss
because I just felt
like I deserved it.
I was very shy kid,
so it did take me a while,
but when it finally did happen,
it was slimy and not particularly enjoyable,
but I was still incredibly
proud of myself.
The first gig I ever went to was
The Magic Numbers in Bristol somewhere,
which was nice but not a
particularly interesting story.
However, the first gig that I ever played
was when I was in my first band.
We were called
"Half Wink."
No we didn't realize
how stupid the name was.
We played two songs at
our school's Christmas fair.
I wrote both of them and
have no memory of either,
and although the attentive audience
consisted exclusively of our parents,
I still remember
it being quite fun.
Now although I don't have any memory
of wanting a job when I was little,
I do have this one distinct memory
of me in my first year of school
sitting in front of a computer and deciding
that I, Charlie McDonnell, little Charlie,
wanted to be a stay-at-home dad
with brown curly hair and a beard.
Needless to say, that is
still my ultimate life goal.
In day to day life, the strangest thing
I've probably eaten is pheasant,
which, boringly, is sort of
just like fancy chicken,
although when I had mine,
it came with bullets still in the bird,
and I didn't know
that at the time,
so I could have killed
myself chocking. Yay.
I did once drink a
milkshake containing
ketchup and fish fingers
among other things though,
so apparently, my dietary choices
can be pretty out there
so long as it's for the
purposes of the internet.
Now personally,
I appreciate the fact that
my name is relatively simple,
common, and uncomplicated
because it just made
my life nice and easy,
so naturally when
I have children,
I'm going to name all
eight of them Charlie.
No surname either,
just Charlie.
No, in terms of specific names,
that's up to me and the person
that I decide to have the babies
with if I even decide to have babies,
which I don't know yet.
Now although I don't have
a favorite school teacher,
my favorite teacher,
generally, is Mrs. McKuen,
who used to give me speech and drama
lessons after school every single week.
I was such a shy kid
when I was younger,
and so I don't think that I would have started
YouTube if it hadn't been for Mrs. McKuen
giving me the confidence to put
myself out there into the world.
So, thanks Vivian.
That was good.
I never had a group
of school friends.
There is no fun way to
say that sentence.
Now, I don't think
anybody hated me.
In fact, I could get along pretty well
with just about anybody in school,
but I just never
found my place.
It was only after I left school
and discovered YouTube
that my choice of potential friends
widened exponentially,
and I found people that I really connected
with, so thank you the Internet.
My favorite place in the
world is right here,
in my office, in my house,
in London.
It's not particularly exciting or
thrilling or anything like that.
It's just comfortable,
and it's where my friends are,
or if they're not here right now,
it's where they can always come.
And ultimately, that's just what
means more to me.
Not the places in my life
but the people.
I'm only going to
tag one person:
because you can't have
over a thousand subscribers
and not have even one video
on your channel.
It's just rude, alright.
Bye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE:You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Here's something I probably should
have told you about ages ago.
Whoo!
QualiTea T-shirts.
Imagine the size of the stamp
that was required to create that beast.
I'm yet to get over my discomfort
of selling things to you,
which is probably
a good thing,
but I wouldn't have made this if
people hadn't asked me to make it,
so if you want it,
here it is,
and if you don't want it,
how'd you like that?
Whooooaaaa oooooh!